こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
僕ですね関わってるYouTuberさん
そんな多い方ではないんですけれどもそれ
でも
仲良くして
くださってるYouTuberとか中には
僕のことを慕ってくれて先輩というか
なんか師匠というかちょっとこうはじめ
さんみたいな感じで
仲良くもしてくれる後輩の
YouTuberとか11年ぐらいかな
長い間YouTuberやってきて
いろんなYouTuberさんとか動画
クリエイターさんとか後輩ができたり
仲良くしてきたんですけれどもいつから
だっけないつからだっけというか皆さん
知ってますかね多分知ってるでしょはじめ
の動画見てる人はちょっと前何年か前に
ですね何年か前によく一緒に動画に出てた
んですけれども
縦面というYouTuberというか後輩
がいたんですけれども全然動画出なくなっ
たじゃないですか一時期すごい手伝って
もらってたんですけど連絡はちまちま撮っ
てたんですけどもだんだん連絡取らなく
なってなんかある日を境に
LINEとか連絡しても全く連絡つかなく
なって
で周りの後輩とかに聞いても全然知らな
いっていう
行方不明消息不明の状態になってまして
もう連絡の取りようがない彼がどこで何を
しているのかもう生きてるのかもわからな
いっていう状況が実は長い間続いてまして
わりと心配してってなんやかんや仲良かっ
たので大丈夫かなと思って連絡してたん
ですけど全くもう連絡も何も取れず本当に
行方不明でどこで何をしてるかもわからな
いっていう状態が続いてなんですけれども
そんな状況がずっと続いてたんですけれど
も
今日
彼を見つけました
ラーメン屋さんにいました
どうぞ
こんにちは
ちょっと待って
髪の毛どうしたの
そうですね前髪がない髪型になってます
いじめられてるの
取らないです誰かにやられたところでは
ないです
というわけでしばらく連絡取れなかったん
ですけども建て面に
奇跡的に本当に偶然ね本当に偶然です
ラーメン屋さんで再開することができまし
たお久しぶりですお久しぶりです
なんで連絡返さなかったの
そうですね連絡
[音楽]
返さなかったというよりか返せなかった
返せなかった結構で頻繁にね電話したのよ
毎日とかじゃないけど
週1ぐらい
マジでなんかあなたのことだから死んでる
んじゃないかとマジで
[笑い]
[音楽]
実はその
携帯をその使って携帯連絡取るやつ携帯が
壊れてしまいました
壊れてしまってで違う形態にしてでその
携帯で色々データとか
復帰しようかなと思ったところその
経済がですね
恥ずかしい話なんですけど
携帯代
滞納しすぎちゃってその
携帯番号が死んじゃってなんか色々データ
とか復帰できなくなっちゃってみたいな
感じです
ごめんなさいなるほどねでも立て麺と
ずっとLINEで連絡してたからさ電話
番号もなくてあそうですねもう本当に連絡
のしようがなくてサーベルと仲いいんです
よ花火と仲いいんですけどサービスと連絡
取ったのわりと最近ですよ実はそう
サーフェと連絡取ったのも最近なんですよ
本当にしばらく連絡が取れなくて1年
ぐらい経ってそうだよねそんぐらい経っ
てるですねいやもう1年以上ちゃんと連絡
取り合ってないっていう状態だったんです
よでねまずそもそも何で盾麺とめっちゃ
動画出てくれてたじゃないですか何で
そんな動画出なくなったかっていうと建前
もYouTuberを目指してたんだよね
そうです僕もステーションという
YouTubeのチャンネルで
YouTuber目指してたんだけど
難しいじゃんYouTubeで食ってる
のっていやマジで難しい難しいそれはもう
感じたはい感じましたもうかなり目標を
決めて目標って達せれなかったらもう
ない道に行くってもう行くか行かない
かっていうその目標を掲げてから頑張って
たんですけどもそれがちょっと残念ながら
目標達成できずYouTubeから離れ
てってそれと同時に俺とも回数が離れて
たっていう感じでちょっと連絡取る回数
だったりあの機会が減ったりはしてたん
ですけれども
元気だったとりあえず
元気ですしっかりと
いろいろ聞きたいことあるのよ
何してたの何してた
YouTubeはどうしたの
YouTubeは
達成できなかった5万人だっけえっと
7778だからだいぶもう忘れ
ちゃったななんか7から7とかぐらいで
7万人とか目標決めてたんですね
やっててで結局その1年経った時にその
目標の数字より下でどうすんのみたい
になったと自分もやっぱ諦められないな
みたいなちょっと待っておつめさんみたい
自分諦められないなみたいになってやめる
んじゃなくて
休止するみたいな形をとってでそっから
休止開けてちょっと出したりもしたんです
なんかちまちま動画出してたよ
でもなんか
[音楽]
これどうなんだろうみたいな自分でもなん
かどういう方向性でやったら
いいなんかもうわけわかんなくなっちゃっ
て自分結構
毎日投稿もしたけどみたいな
[笑い]
じゃあYouTube活動とかさネット
活動は今全くしてないんだそうですね全く
手つけてない何してるの今はなんか大丈夫
か大丈夫です正社員でを
[音楽]
現場作業員という形
で働いておりますちゃんと働いてるのはい
働いております
ちゃんと
働いてるのね
正社員です
切り替えて次の目標に動けてるのマジで
すごいなって思いますありがとうござい
ますちゃんと働いてたのねはい
働いてますかちゃんと働いてるのか
ありがとうございます
1000万人おめでとうございます
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
彼もね今日初めてね4億円のうちに来たん
ですよ
初めてです
[音楽]
か
どこに住んでるのなんか静岡に住んでたら
さ目撃情報とか来ると思うんだけど全く
なくてどこなの
東京です東京なんだ東京です
東京に会社があってで働いてるんですけど
出張が主でまあまあ東京にいるにゃいるん
です家があるにはあるんですけどほとんど
いろんなところに
その髪型は仕事で怒られたりしないの
大丈夫です自分先にしとこか
でもなんか誰かのtiktokで見てよえ
誰のですかなんか
静岡駅の前とかかななんかこの
プレート下げてて絶対笑わせますみたいな
やつで何だっけ俺見たやつがね
tiktok載ってたんだけど
たくさんカタツムリがある美味しそう食べ
ちゃおううまいうまい
まいまいますそれは
路上でなんかダンボール掲げて一発ギャグ
やりますっていうのでやっぱ面白い人間で
ありたいっていうのがあるんではい
YouTubeやった頃からずっとそこの
ユーモアのセンスだけはちょっと
磨きたいとか
落としたくないなってなかったんでそれで
やってた時期はありましたすごいそれ
できる
度胸というか
勇気がすごいよあとその行方不明の時に俺
がめっちゃ心配になった出来事があって
なんかインスタのDMで知らない人から
辰巳さん見かけましたって連絡来て
警察署で出入りしてましたみたいな
大丈夫です
かね
マジになっちゃうから
本当に体調も変わりなくですかはい大丈夫
です思いきがとか病気もなく体大丈夫です
か俺はもう大丈夫大丈夫
元気にやってるよただねやっぱその何やっ
て仲良かったじゃんめっちゃいろんなとこ
一緒に行ったりさもうやばかったですもう
ずっともう毎日のように今日行っていい
ですか今日行っていいですか
ずっと
兄弟のように仲良かった時期があったから
ちょっと連絡が取れなくなった時は
寂しかったなと思いました僕もです本当に
俺はそうでもないえもうさお仕事はどうな
の
仕事でもまあやっとちょっと分かり始めた
かなぐらいのまだまだ全然ですね
続けていけそう
頑張ります
もうYouTubeはじゃあやらないって
こと
結構俺逸材だと思ってるのよ
いやでも心残りがいっぱいあるんですよ
やっぱりまだ何か
まだいけるんじゃないかみたいなでも今の
YouTube
離れちゃったんで今のYouTube
じゃあバンってやりますってなった時に
多分何もわかんないですよノウハウとかが
なくてもできるのがYouTubeだとは
思うんだけどね
[音楽]
わかります大丈夫大丈夫はい分かります
分かります
聞いたことある顔わかんないです
名前は聞いたことあります
えっとフラとビンゴ違うやばいやばい
あぶ切りさん
大和さん
[音楽]
ゆうたさん
ヒューがさ
もう一人いますよねもう一人えっと
ゆうたさんえっとえっと
[音楽]
今の仕事とYouTuber一緒にやっ
ちゃダメだうわそういうのは多分ないと
思います俺がセメントその何年か前に一緒
にずっと行った時心配だったのがもう
YouTube1本で生きていくぜ感が
すごかったじゃん
生活もできないのにそれがすごい俺心配で
縦目のご了承も心配されてたからだから俺
はそれどこかでやっぱタイミング決めて
続けられるかどうかを定める
判断するタイミングあとはいいんじゃない
かなと思ってるけど今そうやってちゃんと
仕事もやりつつちゃんと職について生活し
てるわけでしょそれと一緒だったら全然
やっていいんじゃないと思うけどねまあ
落ち着いたらいいんじゃないそうですね
仕事が落ち
着き一緒にやろうってちょっと絶対難しい
と思うからまず髪型なんとかしようこれ
どうするのが正解です
YouTubeやってるかと思ったもん
降ろしたら言いづらいんだけど
こんにちはもうどっちもいやでもほんと
良かった建物元気でもうそれ確認できた
だけでも良かったよ心配されているって
嬉しいですねはいありがとうございます
もうちょっと早く欲しかったスマホだけ
ちゃんと
払いなさいよ料金しっかり払いますあと
本当にちゃんと仕事してて俺は
素直に偉いなと思います切り替えて
ちゃんと仕事しててなんかやらなそうな
イメージだったから
絶対正社員なんかならないぞみたいな
ちょっと尖ってたもんですけども
ナンパもしてないのかもうなんかないです
ねやっぱ仕事忙しいの
[音楽]
[笑い]
それはちょっと感動したよ悪いことして
ないよねもちろんですわかった
ちょっと元気でまた飯でも行こう頭に連れ
てください仕事頑張れありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
頑張ります
おやすみおやすみなさい今までありがとう
[音楽]